my name is Victor and believe it or not
I fell in love with surfing 13 years ago
when I was surfing for the first time in
Santa Cruz California my high school
photography teacher had taken all the
tas out for a class trip and I remember
all just on a surfboard learning how to
paddle and outside and I felt him pushed
me out of nowhere and he just told me
Victor
stand up quick and then I just popped up
and I felt this wave just riding me all
the way to shore and I'll never forget
that feeling of everything just washing
away and the only thing on your mind
is the board and where the waves gonna
take you on this ride and I would end up
chasing that feeling for the next 10
years all across the west coast and all
around the world because I just love
traveling and surfing that much but then
one unlucky day I decided to play a game
of basketball that would change my life
forever basically I'd suffered a freak
accident where everything in my left
knee tore and exploded leaving me
crippled in bed for three months in
doing rehab for the rest of my life for
the next three years I would learn how
to run and climb again but surfing was
one thing I was too afraid to pick up
what if I was on the ocean and my knee
decided to act up or worse just explode
again and leave me stranded or drowning
you know the ocean so I just never
really wanted to pick up surfing again
but I recently went to Hawaii for a
family trip and figured what better
place to test my knee them there I've
served most of the islands in Hawaii and
I know the waves are pretty forgiving
there and also my brother would be
nearby
so something they did happen he could
always help me out so here's my first
time surfing in three years coming back
from a crippling injury
jc/juan your bike right and it's true
you don't really forget how to surf it's
just a matter of getting your feet wet
pun intended
although all the running swimming I did
for rehab didn't really help me much for
serve me because I was still so out of
shape
struggling to catch any waves let's not
forget to mention that you're feeding
it's 30 other surfers trying to catch
one wave it's pretty brutal out there
but then you do catch one wave and then
it makes it all worth it until you
realize that your knee isn't quite 100%
and you lose control of your board
almost killing another surfer luckily I
was able to jump off my board and pull
on the leash before I almost chopped his
head off thankfully he was super chill
didn't freak out about it
right it's so frustrating though three
years ago I had just returned from
traveling and surfing around Philippines
and then one random basketball game with
people I didn't know what changed the
course of my life I still can't recall
everything that happened all I could
remember was I was going for a layup and
then my opponent tripped me from behind
causing me to land on my left knee I
pretty much just blacked out from there
and when I came to my senses I looked
down I saw my knee flushed into my thigh
and keep in mind I had never broken a
bone or torn a ligament anything serious
in my life
great asset for Kenny åkesson to have a
seat that stretch the floor with
it almost seen as he
he's gonna miss the rest of the season
you can see him just shaking his head
there he's saying I'm done I'm done as
soon as he landed on it Jeremy Lin
season came to an abrupt end on
Wednesday night the Nets guard suffered
a ruptured patella tendon my what the
patellar tendon is one of the biggest
tendons in your body that keeps your
kneecap all connected to the muscles and
without that tendon you have no way to
lift your leg or strain your leg out I
would eventually get surgery which in
itself was the most painful thing I've
experienced my life to this day I
remember waking up in my sleep screaming
holding onto my headboard because I feel
like my knee was about to explode it was
ripping apart from the seams on fire and
no amount of morphine or painkillers
could calm the pain down finally after
six weeks bequite my leg completely
straight so that the tendon can heal or
it would rip again I finally went in for
my first checkup all right yeah I
couldn't even bend if I wanted to it was
just so painful and there was just so
much scar tissue built up I remember
when I asked the doctor how long it
would take for my knee to fully recover
he said that it'll never be back at 100%
had Ari lost too much muscle mass and
there was just too much damage done
there and most he said maybe 85 or 90%
depending on rehab so I went to rehab
facility for a year to strengthen my
left knee learn how to walk all over
again and eventually try to surf on this
day I didn't have much trouble paddling
or standing up really but I couldn't
control the board very well since most
of my weight was on my front left knee
which wasn't had a hundred percent and
must have tried standing up so many
times but when I finally caught a good
one the wave decided to slap me right in
the face
caused me to fall off and almost drown
Oh yep so I almost killed another surfer
I almost drowned I took that as a sign
of paddle back in and just give up I had
cuts all over my leg from the reef and
that knee was so red and swollen I was
ready to call it quits but then I look
at my knee and the message that I've
tattooed on it I even made a BuzzFeed
video on it people get tattoos and their
scars and in a video I got a tattoo that
reads it's not how you fall but how you
stand back up and in that moment I was
reminded of all the blood sweat and
tears had sacrificed to get back to even
90% so I paddled back out and waited for
the perfect wave which finally came for
whatever reason everything on this wave
just kind of clicked I said it with so
much confidence and I just rode the wave
out with style then I just kept catching
normal ways and has so much fun as it
were my first day of surfing 13 years
ago it's uncanny hair our human nature
yearns for something more when it's
taken away from us in my case it was my
name and all the things associated with
that like traveling climbing and surfing
so I urge you if you're going through a
hardship whether it's mentally or
physically try your hardest to find out
things that want to find your joy and
pursue those to the best of your
abilities even though money will never
be 100% I can fully appreciate the
things that wants to for granted and one
day I'll travel the world again surfing
in some exotic location until then
Surf's Up
[Music]
[Applause]